hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Adele buddy
so fast I'm right
Adele
not leaving breath between your sentence
in mine
gotcha gotcha like one complete sentence
ah thank you I appreciate that good
grammar we're gonna watch the trailer
day for a movie called Annabelle and
this is a spin-off of the conjuring
there was a doll character featured in
there called Annabelle creepy little
[ __ ] doll and apparently got such
good responses that that movie was
awesome have you seen it sounds familiar
but no I don't think I've seen it it's
really good actually
Vera Farmiga Oh Vera from me go you know
that is the only sounds hot there yeah
she is hot anyway huh ya know is a great
[ __ ] movie I want to see this movie
already because I like the conjuring
enough to want to watch this hopefully
it's good is it scary this yes must be a
hormone about Annabelle yeah but it's
like actually like spooky supernatural
not like bloodfest kind of scary alright
let's check this out I like the name
Annabelle
yeah I'm sure you'll love this movie
okay close your eyes I was waitin on
this until the baby but open your eyes
my god is the one okay I'm scared okay
I'm really scared it was what a creepy
[ __ ] doll like she fits right oh man
sorry it scared easily John oh I like a
baby yeah next door I heard screen is
official stay here check it out this way
smart smart yeah don't go check it out
so I'm gonna go next door and check out
the hoard my husband
oh my god we got the neighbor I don't
know
No
Oh No
oh I do not like the name out of bell
anymore how creepy oh my god that looks
so creepy that stupid main characters
again but it's creepy okay they died
pretty quickly mm were they killed
I thought I thought think oh I thought
the intruders were killed and then like
the spirits gonna live an animal or
something
oh you're horrible at these assumptions
I am I night horrible I do ya know so
you're not gonna watch it uh no why what
if it gets great reviews I might watch
it at home with the lights on in the
middle of the day we be naked no no okay
I was gonna offer to watch it with you
at Newman would you see it yeah with you
naked snow by yourself in a dock cinema
oh by myself oh god no no can do our
movies along the computer horrible idea
horrible I know mmm that question hate
that question what question the [ __ ]
would I watch us alone in the theater
what's wrong with you don't put me in
that mindset piracy movies or in the
theater horror movies
no yeah good look look ashamed of
yourself for even thinking about that it
looks creepy the conjuring got great
feedback from audiences and critics it's
a rare horror movie that gets like good
reviews and I really I want I want to
watch this I mean it looks like it has
similar to type of cinematography and I
love a good DP on a movie like this
husband to me just so stupid yeah
neighbor problems let me go check it out
like why yeah what kind of [ __ ]
neighbor does that we can call the cops
if you think you're in something creepy
little dolls coming to life like Chucky
oh yeah yeah no dolls freak me out
dolls really free
hmm they they should all be burnt really
we should start like a book burning but
with dolls did you used to play with
dolls no I had a Winnie the Pooh Bear
doll
fun fact that I've his giant money
Winnie the Pooh Bear like hugging toy
and then I could then there was a hole
in the crotch that I would practice on
so really a first love is we need to
hear yeah yeah yeah never got pregnant
though but always let me finish inside
anyway if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe and if you want to
subscribe to Adele's movie originally
movie jus Channel yeah you might have
subscribe to Adele's movie review
channel you can subscribe right here so
thank you guys and what we do at this
point in the video what do we do Adele
at this point in the video it's time for
shout out yeah good you dance right here
shout outs no big motions see you down
the dance floor boogie yeah this is the
move this is like so it gets all the
ladies this move what's up girl
what's up why is it when you doing it
looks dirty what do you mean maddinames
i'm fingering it but you're right
anything
thank you yeah okay ma'am but if I the
animal doll I'd have sex with her before
the woody and poodle any day nope take
that back even if that much cut your
head off while are you doing it yeah
yeah changed my wife ginger mine
räikkönen STD anyway shoutout Ben
Sanderson um I did a Ryan Gosling rap
song it was all dedicated to Ryan
Gosling you guys should check out that
video
pretty hot felt it it was just the truth
you can speak the truth Ben Sanderson he
said brilliant song Ryan can I have a
shout out please love your videos I've
subbed you and all three of my channels
he has 3 channels all three of them
subbed Wow such a dedication so can you
do me a favor
um can you watch any video you watch can
you rewatch them with your other two
channels as well so we can increase the
views you know that's like a good plan
so that would really help out thanks Ben
thanks man Shanthi
Sanderson smelly Jewish Sanderson is
that a Jewish name I don't know my hair
saying I'm assuming he's Jewish
can you go 100 without offending summary
yeah people uh yeah I mean it's all
about targeting millions of people and
offending them interesting strategy
yeah it works it works it works I've got
a lot of death threats but it's okay
right Ryan you didn't even ask for a
shout-out a little bait a minute it's a
guy here named right Ryan righ D great
what sad video he said on my ryan
gosling rap song but dude - tag me
hashtag I'm not Ryan hey man that's
looking cool think you like named
himself after you I'm pretty sure he did
sorry dude dude Thank You Man you
deserve a shadow you chose the right
name huh oh I didn't get it now I get it
you're either wrong or Ryan right that's
how I it's basically it those are the
two kinds of people you know when it
comes down to anything
Jerry wrong or Ryan right boys Ari yeah
Norma read tag Aloha tap oosa oh oh
shout out okay tag Aloha to Pusa then
you put up the smiley face and the
smiley face yeah but it's not just a
smiley face it's like a D yeah it's like
a big smile oh it's like a Pringle smile
um what the hell are you
I can't figure out what race that is I
like to guess the races Samoan some oh
you think you Samoan or she hi are you
she I got really excited just that
Samoan she ya Samoan female do you
that'd be hot Qi moment that's what we
call you okay just spit a lot I get your
foot you tainted I'm sorry
she mowing DUP busie actually that
sounds like it could be like an a dish
at a restaurant ooh what kind of food
would it be
what would be in the dish macaroni and
cheese that's some fancy is my Kearny NJ
shredded beef Oh with a side of peas
okay mm-hmm so if you were a food tag
Aloha that's what you would be that's
you be you be the cause of a lot of
vomiting JT McBride shouting there you
go
uh yeah um you're asking if you could
have a shout-out maybe maybe I'll give
you shut up Jaden Jaden
what do you Will Smith's kid McBride
ways he's I he's Will Smith's kid and
Danny McBride kid and the hybrid of them
he's a black fat curly-haired guy didn't
even say please Jayden just shout out
just shout out dude come on man you got
eyes on him please in there you got to
offer something to me
usually people offer to select my dick
which none of you have John by the way
I've been waiting but I haven't Astro
baited in four months
that's not sure masturbate before Adele
got here forgot to wash my hands anyway
Jaden yeah thanks for letting me
sexually harass my friend [ __ ] you Jane
okay let's go he's not a little kid oh
that's the first time I've saw it on
camera
yeah Jaden your shadows done
congratulations
seriously I masturbated before you got